it is five years since the london bridge
terrorist attack
but there's no number on grief for their
souls were pleasing to the lord
therefore he took them quickly from the
midst
of wickedness
for those gathered here today is about
reflection prayer and memories
what happened that night will stay with
me for for the rest of my life
we are creatures of our experiences
and you can't
um remove that experience the idea is is
to build on top of that experience and
and and make as much of a strength as
possible
local resident amir eden witnessed the
horror in 2017 when eight people were
killed after three attackers drove into
pedestrians in borough market
and then went on a stabbing frenzy i
never thought something like this would
happen to this community and this
community is a very special place to me
to many people who live here
and and it felt you know a defilement an
attack an attack on everything that we
stand for everything that we believe in
as a plaque bearing the names of those
killed was unveiled the mayor of london
and the prime minister were among those
sending tributes
when faced with the worst of humanity
boris johnson said
this city responded with its best and
refused to be cowed in the face of
terror
in these five years we've grown stronger
together
and i know that you are all my family
at the local mosque the dean of
southwark cathedral attends friday
prayers
terrorism will not divide this community
sadia chaudhary sky news in southwark